después de la anulación de los
resultados de noviembre hay garantías en
este proceso
bueno las garantías tienen que
garantizarse la todo el que participe en
este proceso recuerda que la última vez
las últimas elecciones del 21 de
noviembre
maduro hizo que la
observación de la unión europea saliera
más temprano del país lo cual quiere
decir que la observación que hay en este
momento es la que siempre ha habido en
los procesos chavistas redes sin amigos
del del proceso que por cierto no son
observadores sino que son llamaba
compañía entes y esto es una diferencia
bien importante en todo caso esto va a
depender de la manifestación de voluntad
que haga la gente
he visto fotos bastante
buenas ese sentido de la participación
estar viendo una participación
importante y a mayor participación
evidentemente son menores los chances
del turismo de ganar estas elecciones
bueno y más allá de ser la cuna de hugo
chávez marina tiene alguna importancia
estratégica para el gobierno de nicolás
maduro
bueno
en barinas es un estado rico barinas
tienen o tienen ganadería tiene
agricultura es un país casi vecino de
perdón un estado casi vecino de colombia
tiene una cantidad importante de
población
en los llanos venezolanos
es un estado que siempre ha tenido una
importancia
muy grande y yo creo que el perder
barinas sería un golpe moral bastante
importante para el chavismo no solamente
por ser un estado que ha estado bajo la
égida de los chaves desde 1999 sino
porque además y esto es muy importante
mencionar no está dejando en evidencia
los enfrentamientos muy graves que
existen dentro del chavismo con
declaraciones de alguien y chávez en
contra de arriaza y arriaza haciendo
campaña en contra de los ojos del
chavismo y de los chávez
si yo fuese el de la oposición bueno y
la oposición justamente denunció que
para esta jornada hay una importante
presencia militar en el estado cuál
puede ser el objetivo de este aumento en
el pie de fuerza
bueno yo yo no lo quiero hacer directo
mayor asunto siempre había un despliegue
militar cada vez que hay un proceso
electoral
barinas no tiene suficientes hombres en
armas como para tomar los centros de
votación como se hace en todos los
procesos electorales o no hubo necesidad
extras de la gente soldados de otros
estados o no esto no lo veo como un
asunto
por el cual hay que preocuparse en
particular